from surviving a trip through the Event
Horizon of a black hole to Impossible
clouds made of solid ice Interstellar
went lighter on science than it did on
fiction
the main reason scientists are looking
for a way of Earth and Interstellar is
that the atmosphere won't be able to
support humans for much longer
specifically it stated that nitrogen is
staying in the atmosphere and dropping
oxygen levels making it difficult to
sustain life on the planet this is due
to something referred to as the blight a
plague that is wreaking havoc with our
food and threatening our Air Supply the
last people to starve will be the first
to suffocate sure Interstellar is
science fiction not a documentary but
could something like the blight actually
happen according to physics today it is
extremely unlikely that a single disease
could Wipe Out the whole of humanity
astrobiologist David grinspoon recorded
an episode of inquiring minds with host
David Corn after watching the film and
commented on the various scientific
inaccuracies he picked up on he noted
that the whole thing about nitrogen
staying in the atmosphere was
problematic telling his host they say oh
there's this blight and it's building up
the nitrogen and that's going to draw
down the oxygen and anybody who knows
about planetary atmospheres is going to
sit there at that point and go that's a
bunch of BS promoting the fact that they
didn't come up with something more
believable grinspoon went on to say why
couldn't they run it by somebody it
wouldn't change the plot they could have
said slightly smarter things and more
realistic things
one of the central conceits of
interstellar is that the brave team of
explorers can only venture to the far
reaches of the universe via a wormhole
in the general vicinity of Saturn for
those who don't know how wormholes work
thus allow Dr ramali to explain so a
wormhole bends face like this so you can
take a shortcut through
a higher Dimension it's widely theorized
that under the right conditions these
shortcuts could be used as a sort of
subway system through the Galaxy as
exciting as that Prospect is the truth
is nobody has ever actually found an
existing Wormhole and as of the making
of this video they are purely
theoretical Professor Martin Barstow of
the Royal Astronomical Society was quick
to point this fact out in his critique
of the film's scientific accuracy though
he's also quick to acknowledge it's a
solid storytelling device Barstow told
the Daily Mail there's no direct
evidence such things exist in the
universe we know about black holes but
the idea of something connecting
different parts of space is very much an
idea in its infancy but from a dramatic
point of view you've got to have
something like this in the film like
that otherwise it doesn't work in his
interview The Daily Mail lauded
scientific author Lee Billings was a bit
harsher in his criticism of Wormhole
Theory he'd sold the Tabloid saying that
we have to rely on borderline miracles
of physics makes it easier but also
makes it way harder we have no idea of
stable wormholes exist on a macro scopic
scale wheel or not the Wormhole and
Interstellar remains one of the film's
most visceral and Visually arresting
creations
it seems that another enthralling scene
from Interstellar is not entirely
accurate the moment comes in the third
Act of Christopher Nolan's film and
finds Cooper leaving the team's
endurance spacecraft in hopes of
lightening the ship's load thus enabling
brands that orbit a supermassive black
hole using its gravitational pull to
visit several orbiting planets once
inside Gargantua Cooper ejects from his
spacecraft beginning a fully psychedelic
Journey on power's 2001 as Space Odyssey
at the end of The Journey Cooper is
still very much alive and even lands
near a shiny planet-sized space station
the moment makes for Grand storytelling
and adds some truly astounding visual
elements however as Professor Martin
Barstow told the Daily Mail there's
absolutely no chance Cooper could have
survived inside a black hole let alone
communicate it with the outside world
Barstow explained the gravitational
field is extremely intense and changes
very quickly the idea is that anything
that falls into it becomes like
spaghetti stretched out by gravity so
there's no chance that anything or
anybody could survive in a black all
communicating out of one is awesome
impossible Lee Billings takes matters
further explaining that radiation from a
black hole would likely kill you before
you ever actually got inside he told the
Daily Mail I think if astronauts ended
up getting as close to the accretion
desk around a supermassive black hole as
they did in the film in reality they
would have had a bad time those things
are going to be pouring off hard
radiation from the superheated material
that piles up around the Event Horizon
so it seems even if the film's black
hole trip made for marvelously
mind-melting Cinema more than just
Cooper's mind would have melted in
reality
it seems there may be a few problems
with a bittersweet ending of
interstellar the one which posits that
not only did Amelia Brandon manage to
Traverse the orbit of a supermassive
black hole but she actually found a
habitable planet in its orbit once again
the concepts behind such magnificent
narrative twists aren't all that
far-fetched but it's because we know so
little about black holes in general let
alone the spaces surrounding them any
and all depictions of such conditions
are purely theoretical making habitable
planets unlikely even branta self-says
as much in the film as she explains why
life would never take root on such
planets but when you're orbiting a black
hole
can happen it sucks in asteroids and
comets other events which would
otherwise reach you Professor Martin
boster in particular wonders if a planet
could really survive near such a large
black hole he told the Daily Mail
there's no reason why they couldn't
orbit a black hole although nobody's
ever detected one what's more likely is
a star orbiting or black hole and a
planetary system around that star any
planetary system Associates it just with
a black hole would probably be consumed
Lee Billings has similar issues with the
film telling the Daily Mail I think
Interstellar is a movie for physicists
not for planetary scientists and I think
you can see that in what they emphasize
was accurate and true science and what's
not there are a lot of problems with the
planet to better illustrate his point
Billings went on to say for example
there's a planet with huge Tides but the
water itself is no shallower than your
ankles or your knees it's not clear
what's causing those crazy Tides maybe
the black hole but if it's pulling that
hard then it would manifest in other
ways beside mile high waves frankly if
you've got to bend the rules a bit to
make that water Planet happen in
interstellar we're happy to allow it
because it remains one of the most
thrilling Creations in modern cinematic
history
Dr Mann is a scientist the team tries to
rescue seconds because his planet can
supposedly maintain life of course this
is a lie frustrated at how inhospitable
the place is he hacks into Kip and
corrupts the data in order to fool his
colleagues into thinking it could be a
new home for humankind one of the most
curious things about the planet is that
it has clouds made of solid ice which is
where Dr man is located are floating ice
clouds something based on real science
far from it according to astrobiologist
David grinspoon there are clouds made of
ice on Earth as well as other planets
but they're little particles of ice and
if you got up to the cloud it would be
all fluffy and you could fly through it
grinspoon told his friend and colleague
David Corn during his interview on the
inquiring minds podcast you couldn't
stand on it and land a ship on it it's
not like it's going to be solid ice
something like that would fall because
of gravity while grinspoon praise the
movie for getting people interested in
black holes and bringing climate change
to the Forefront of conversation he
couldn't help but Express annoyance at
this part of the movie discussing the
ice clouds on man he said is that so
crucial to the plot that they couldn't
wouldn't buy a planet a scientist
one of the few elements that most
scientists can agree on in interstellar
is the design of the film spacecraft
endurance in particular those scientists
agree the ship's circular spinning
design will be a great way to help
generate the necessary artificial
gravity to make Interstellar travel both
possible and livable endurance's design
was hardly speculative however as it was
apparently modeled directly from aspects
of the International Space Station but
while the craft itself appears to be a
realistic means of traversing open space
the Billings believes the ease with
which the endurance and its detachable
crust takeoff from planets is more than
a little bit problematic he noted in his
interview The Daily Mail endurance seems
quite plausible in terms of artificial
gravity spinning around to give you that
force that prevents Bones from decaying
in microgravity but despite offering the
filmmakers some credit for getting one
detail correct he would go on to
criticize the unbelievability of the
landing crafts propulsion system saying
the main thing that seemed unrealistic
was whatever propulsion they had to
escape the extreme gravity Wells of a
planet that caused men to age a decade
in an hour Matt Kaplan of the planet
military society would go on to equate
the ship's miraculous propulsion to the
sort of problem even Star Trek found a
way to cleverly sidestep telling the
Tabloid Gene Roddenberry said he created
Transporters for Star Trek because he
didn't want to waste time getting to the
surface and back we're happy to forgive
Nolan for possibly using the miraculous
propulsion as a means of Expediting the
action in interstellar given the film's
nearly three hour run time but given his
dedication to hard science in the film
it seems like he probably could have
indulged a bit more in this particular
time construct
much of interstellar focuses on finding
a new planet and artificial intelligence
plays a significant role in helping
scientists locate Humanity's next home
three different robots are shown
throughout the film and they all look
like something from 2001 A Space Odyssey
but there is much more to them than
their appearances the robots move with
great speed perform scientific tests and
save their human Partners from waves on
aquaplanets is that type of AI realistic
as it turns out it would take an immense
amount of power to run a machine of that
nature according to science ABC aside
from the power there's some man hours
that would go into programming
everything from his vocabulary to the
humor setting which is just not possible
in a single product today at least not
in a version as refined and
deterministic as tasks there are robots
running tests out in the real world but
they are not communicating with humans
and they certainly aren't commenting on
the fact that they have to follow human
orders you do this for us before you get
all theory try to remember that as a
robot I have to do anything you say
hey key light's broken I'm not joking
of course a supermassive black hole
Gargantua is in and of itself one of the
film's most spectacular Creations Nolan
actually turned to renowned theoretical
physicist Dr Kip Thorne to help bring
Gargantua to life on screen the film's
jaw-drop in creation was instantly
hailed as one of the most accurate
depictions of a black hole in the
history of film particularly in
rendering the refracted lensing of light
and if you follow space related news you
will know that the film's black hole
looks shockingly similar to the real
thing but while Gargantua appears to be
quite authentically depicted it seems
Matt Kaplan takes issues with the
concept of its gentle Singularity
Channel they're hardly General this
theoretical concept explains why the
space surrounding the black hole is
surprisingly stable Kaplan does
acknowledge that there is a theoretical
basis for such a concept saying to the
Daily Mail I think they are fairly
certain with a black hole the size of
Gargantua you can get things like that
if it's large enough but until we
actually get to explore one if that ever
happens or have some instruments I can
examine it is really all Theory even if
there's not a ton of actual evidence to
support Nolan's gentle Singularity twist
and Interstellar it seems it's now up to
the scientific establishment to either
prove or disprove one of the film's more
radical theories
foreign